we know beyonce is no stranger to the
academy awards and now for king richard
she is a nominee for original song well
get ready because it looks like queen b
is about to hold court literally on
oscar sunday
[Music]
beyonce is reportedly in deep talks to
open the oscars live with her nominated
song be alive from a tennis court in
compton california it's all top secret
of course but here's what we've
uncovered an eyewitness tells e.t
beyonce was spotted filming something
oscar related on sunday possibly a
run-through or promo at this court in
compton today cleanup was underway and a
tent being torn down of course as
depicted in king richard venus and
serena started their tennis careers on
another compton court just a few miles
from here
[Music]
there's also speculation that the film's
best actor nominee will smith will
introduce beyonce live before he would
presumably head north 22 miles to the
dolby theater it's all these black women
that i get to
protect
and
and shine a light on it's the first year
beyonce's been nominated but she's
performed at three oscar shows
she sang three original song nominees in
2005. in 2007 she brought the drama with
the dreamgirls medley and in 2009 a
salute to musicals with hugh jackman
oh and it would also be beyonce's first
performance at an awards show since she
electrified the audience at the grammys
in 2017. you and me can make it right
now
also expected to perform
first-time nominees billy eilish and
phineas their theme from the james bond
movie no time to die won best song at
the critics choice awards finis came up
with this just chord progression and
immediately we were just like oh
we wrote the whole song
[Music]